[Music]
foreign
[Music]
institutions scary place I was actually
12 when I got admitted there and then it
was like I spent my 13th and 14th
birthday there
why were you there because your dad said
you shouldn't have been there you know I
came to the conclusion that everybody
has their own agenda you know my mom had
her own agenda I don't know exactly what
that was but my agenda was to make it
out on top of that tough spot at the
time Kate said Collins
institutionalization was due to quote
special needs he's missing Colin wasn't
there each unique child is receiving
exactly what they need your mom said
Colin has special needs there's a fairly
fluid diagnosis of what those needs are
it's not something that has only
impacted me or him our entire family has
been impacted when you hear that what do
you think it's unfortunate that that's
how my mom you know
phrased me as a person you know I don't
see those things and I don't think
anybody else sees those things and I
hope that if we met again one day she
would understand that you know it's not
the case Colin told me he was finally
able to leave the institution after
writing John this gut-wrenching letter
begging for help quote you're my dad My
Savior Please help me I'm counting on
you to get me out of here Daddy I love
you you asked him for help to get you
out of that place right
um what was going on I was in a dark
place mentally I think being in a place
like that does more damage than it helps
you so I was hopeless Colin moved in
with his dad and twin sister Hannah in
2018 John says he was granted temporary
full custody your mom didn't show up to
the custody here did it bother you she
didn't show up it didn't really bother
me I mean they just gave it to my dad
and you know she wasn't there to put her
word in so
that's what happened sadly Colin's
relationship with Kate and his six other
siblings remains estranged but he is
hopeful that eventually it can be
rebuilt if there's a message you could
send to your mom what would you say to
her
um it's unfortunate that we didn't have
a relationship but I'm doing very well
do you get to talk to your other
brothers and sisters no I have not
spoken with my siblings and and probably
five or six years now and it's tough do
you want to send a message to them
because I'm sure they'll see this you
know I love them to death you know
they're the only hmm sorry no I get it
there's nothing like the bond between
brothers and sisters
there you wanna do you can somebody get
a tissue real quick okay grab a tissue
can you actually just re-ask question
yeah yeah what would you like to say to
your siblings I love them very much and
I really hope that you know one day when
I have kids that you know my kids will
know their Aunt uncles so let's talk
about right now what's in your future
what are you doing now
um finishing High School graduating I've
always wanted to be a marine so I think
that's the next step would you ever do
reality TV again
um
you know I think you know I've become
somewhat of a natural at it so um I
think it'd be cool to kind of do it now
thank you so much what do you remember
about doing the show something that you
never forget is like the presence of the
cameras like there's always cameras
there they're always on you Colin is
stubborn yet kind fans watch Colin since
he was three years old growing up on TV
John and Kate Plus Eight was one of
TLC's highest rated programs ever can
you stop breathing so loud honey
he's like
it was such a phenomenon that in 2009
10.6 million viewers tuned in to watch
John and Kate's televise separation
announcement uh Kay and I have decided
to separate I'm not very fond of the
idea personally they don't speak now do
you wish they could at least they would
speak to each other if they had the
capability of co-parenting that would be
nice and do it for the sake of our kids
if you guys hadn't done that reality
show do you think your family would be
intact I definitely think they'd still
be together not for the show so John and
Kate Plus 8 basically ruined your family
I I think so in my opinion
[Music]